when Scorsese came out and he said I
don't think these uh superhero movies
are Cinema
I mean I don't know where you stand with
that I'm curious
I kind of felt like oh that's kind of an
elitist attitude I mean Scorsese
certainly one of the greatest filmmakers
of all time I worship the guy's movies
but
I mean it is Cinema I mean is it not
well okay
again it's like he's an old man you
think Scorsese is going to be into
Ant-Man versus the WASP why not but he's
not going to be all right I don't I
don't think he would have been that into
that at 37 forget about how [ __ ] old
he is now all right that's just not his
thing I mean even even me when it comes
to I mean I used to collect Marvel comic
books I loved Marvel comic books and um
you know of all this [ __ ] was coming out
in 86 I would be all down with it you
know they waited till I got too old all
right you know for me to be so into it
but I think it's it's you know it's more
about the fact I mean I ended up talking
to a kid just if you're listening
Brandon I'm talking about you I met a
kid I'd never met before at a at a party
the other day
and he started a conversation with me
and uh he asked me about what I felt
about superhero movies and I know this
kid is like I don't know how old he is
maybe he's six 16 or 17. uh maybe he's a
little older
um but you know he's talking about how
he saw the first Iron Man when he was
four
or five so
to him
Marvel movies and DC movies are movies
right and there's been actually almost
no competition to show him that there
can be anything else so going to the
movies means going to see those movies
right and if it's not that it's the
start Star Wars movies and if it's not
that it's the Harry Potter movies and if
it's not that it's the Transformer
movies
so you don't feel any pressure in making
another movie where you'd have to do
lots of special effects and change your
whole style of filmmaking I mean you're
not gonna no if I wanted to do that I
would do that but I've never really been
a big uh uh um
do a bunch of special effects later kind
of guy I I right I almost kind of I kind
of come from the idea that
if you didn't shoot it on the day it
doesn't count wow yeah it's like no no
we're there with the crew the actors
everything we shot it on the day we sent
the film to the lab it came back it's
done now you can do little tiny things
but I'm very about
um uh uh practical effects no I work
with makeup effects and I work with
animatronic effects or whatever no I
have the K B I have the best effects
team in the world and the idea is no
they're going to create it and we're
going to do it on stage we're gonna
capture it on film
foreign